elles étaient 42 42 équipes à
s'affronter lors de cette 15e édition
des trophées de robotique d'île de
france organisée par planète sciences
une association pour vulgarisation et ce
sont les représentants d'issy les
moulineaux qui l'ont emporté
c'est notre troisième année et comme
toutes les années on les a faits en lego
et cette année on a rajouté quelques
pièces en imprimé à l'imprimante 3d et
on a tous participé et
c'est beaucoup de premiers mois la
compétition aura duré près de dix heures
a rythmé par des matchs est à peine
quelques minutes sur le terrain des
robots téléguidés élaboré par des jeunes
élèves de primaire des collégiens et
lycéens
c'est un cahier des charges doit être
respectée chaque équipe doit trouver le
détail qui fera la différence
cette année la thématique c'est la plage
et différentes actions doivent être
réalisés par les équipes suivant un
cahier des charges de ce cahier des
charges est très libre les équipes faire
comme ils veulent donc pas utiliser les
matériaux qui le souhaitent des mécanos
du bois duval za comme il souhaite et du
moment qu'il qu'il puisse marquer des
points donc en fonction des actions
qu'ils poseraient les il peut marquer
plus ou moins deux points sur le podium
aux côtés d'issy les moulineaux savigny
le temple ou encore neuilly sur marne
ces trois équipes représenteront la
région les 9 et 10 avril prochains lors
de la finale nationale dans l'aisne